gonna die alone and I feel fine tell us
we're dudes what's the inspiration for
this title well I was inspired by a lot
of people I know who died alone and I
think that I hear that all people people
always think it means
but like I'm single and I'm like no I'm
gonna die alone that's not what I mean I
just mean you shouldn't do anything in
this life whether it's get married or
have kids to guarantee what's gonna go
on in your future right like I had all
these neighbors growing up old ladies
and they were all widows and I just
thought that's a hot when you get older
like your husband dies or kids move away
and you just watch you know prices right
all day and you know mrs. Stevens my
neighbor she her husband had died our
kids grew up and she fell changing a
light bulb and had a heart attack and
her dog ate her face and I think that
I'm no but her you're gonna love this
her dog me me anything you're gonna love
this what how does this story get better
because it's about Mimi's revenge she
used to walk Mimi and she'd stick her
cane and go come on meme and kind of
stick it up her butt hole and Mimi would
be like and so I feel like when mrs.
Stevens died Mimi was like that's it I'm
going for the face and then she got so I
feel like whatever but here's my point
so Mimi was like ah now the tables have
turned woof woof
I'm like that every day here I'm just
sitting here looking at his face if you
pity people you know who aren't married
or divorce or something you never know
how you're gonna exact mrs. Stephens
wasn't getting married going and then
Brad and I will be together forever or a
dog will eat my face no no that was not
the way it was supposed to end no god
rest her soul her eternal soul
yeah she really appreciates this shout
out she's in heaven well you thank you
watch television now the title implies
that you are not going to have kids you
don't think you're gonna have kids well
I definitely know I don't want to and
I'm not good with kids because like I
babysat like I'm not a monster I've had
interacted with children but I don't
know how to talk to them like I don't
know what to say when they I babysat
this kid who said Jen how long ago was
this but I was 14 okay so it was a long
time ago like three or four years yeah
babies Jenna because is there a God and
I go oh I don't know and he goes well I
thought adults have all the answers I go
uh and he goes is murder real and I go
what do you mean murder he goes stabbing
people and killing them is that gonna
happen to me I go oh no I go murders not
real where did you see about murder he
said on TV I go that's all made up
because there's no such thing as murder
in real life I go nope and I'm like I
nailed this and I shut the light off and
then the next day I got a call from his
mother and she said our son was standing
in our bedroom with a knife saying Jen
said murder isn't real can I stab you
and see if you bleed okay now first of
all I'm gonna say visit is you decide
for yourselves I don't take away from
this story Jen is a bad babysitter I
take away that kids a freaking sociopath
Jennie's there a guy is murder real
those one doesn't follow the other
forget Santa Claus and the Easter Bunny
he's right to murder yeah I never
thought about it that way I still don't
want one though because you could get a
murderer you don't know what you're
gonna pop out right
okay well you've really brought the
audience that's gonna know it's
important we knew from the title if you
get a murderer though it's your murderer
yeah